if you are an entrepreneur you can build
a company and you can grow
but if you're if the premise of your
business is that you can have growth
quarter after quarter year after year at
an infinite scale
that is not true
we have clearly run out of planet
and so your metric of success should not
be growth it should be sustainability
what is the longevity of what you're
creating
not how much can you maximize growth
in order to get more than you need
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
meet minal papaya founder and principal
consultant at brevity and wit
minal is the author of equity how to
design organizations where everyone
thrives she's the founder of brevity and
wit a strategy and design firm that
combines human centered design behavior
change science and the principles of
inclusion diversity equity and
accessibility to help organizations
transform themselves and the world
papaya has written for the stanford
social innovation review and the hill
and has been a featured guest on
numerous podcasts and shows including
the kojun mahdi show on wamu she has
also been a keynote speaker for many
conferences inspiring thousands with
their credible authentic and engaging
talks
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
good thank you for having me michael
it's really a pleasure to be here
it's a pleasure having you here where
are you calling from in the world right
now
so i am in the greater dc area in uh
silver spring maryland which is right
outside dc i love it so mental so many
different experiences so many things for
us to talk about and but i'd love to
concentrate on your most recent efforts
and with with the book that you were
that was recently published in september
talking about equity and obviously this
is a topic of conversation in the last a
few years mainly in this last year or
two i believe that's becoming really
really mainstream and but your work you
know is is interesting all around and
with brevity and weight and so i'd love
to learn a little bit about you and then
we'll dive into equity what that means
to you why you're you know why you
decided to dedicate so much of your time
into this and what we're seeing you know
in greater trend about the world so
middle who are you sure so i am the
author of equity how to design
organizations where everyone thrives
which has been published by barrett
kohler i am also the founder and
principal at brevity and wit which is a
strategy and design firm that combines
human centered design behavior change
science and the principles of inclusion
diversity equity and accessibility to
help organizations transform themselves
and the world
okay so i heard a lot of really
interesting things here no let's let's
dig deep into this what do you know
where is the human center design and you
know the behavioral science where how do
those come into play
when we're talking about the question of
equity and diversity in the workplace
yeah so um there's a fundamental truth
that we have to acknowledge that um the
system isn't broken
it is actually working exactly the way
it was designed to work
so uh
you know
it most systems of oppression have been
designed to privilege some at the
expense of others uh in the united
states that is primarily centered around
race and gender and um sexuality and
disability status
right
and so
when we're talking about being able to
create a more equitable world we have to
start with designing more equitable
systems that really gives everyone a
fair shot at opportunity
and so
this distinction
of you know it's not that its system is
broken or was it's working as it was
designed why is this an important
distinction in your mind that we sort of
converge on
i think there's a basic assumption or
myth that the world is somehow neutral
and that the results that we have
are
somehow the
natural outcome of just people's efforts
and that you know we're all working in
some sort of neutral system and that's
not true we like to perpetuate this myth
particularly in the entrepreneurial
circles of that hard work equals success
now it's not that hard work isn't
important but that equation is
not the complete equation the actual
equation is hard work plus system
support equals success
and that
we have done a very good job about
talking about the virtue of hard work
but we have done a very poor job of
unmasking how the system is supporting
certain individuals so for example of
the fortune 500 70
of the ceos have a spouse that does not
work outside the home
it is almost impossible to be a ceo if
you are not married like and
particularly have a family if you are
not married to someone who is going to
pick up all of that
labor at that at home for free
right
that makes intuitive sense as well right
and so then when we talk about why
aren't there women ceos or why aren't
there um more ceos of color the question
is how many of those people have
somebody who lives with them full-time
who is going to pick up the slack
right how many women have a husband like
i do who did all of the housework while
i wrote my book
right
right and obviously that's not
proportional yeah and so if we don't
have that support then we can ascend to
these places of power and success
and so the fact is it's not that we're
not working hard enough it's that the
system has not been designed with us in
mind
as you're now looking at the world
what does it take to design a system
that has this in mind what are what are
some you know you know either you know
very pragmatic or theoretical steps that
we need to take into account as we're
aiming for obviously that type of world
so we want to think about um who has
this organization been designed for
in the past and how relevant is that
today and then how do we center some of
the people who have been pushed to the
margins in our redesign
right so for example most organizations
like i said um have been designed for
straight white men in mind in like the
1950s right where they could commute to
work where they had a spouse who was
picking up all of the emotional and
cognitive labor of the home
where they could one income could send
your kids to college and buy you a house
and allow you to save for retirement
right that does not exist for most
people including the majority of
straight white men
so what if we were to put a different
identity
at the center of our organizations
what if we were to design for single
mothers
right
right now we have a legacy where if you
go on a sales call you can expense
alcohol and drinks and entertainment as
a viable business expense
because back in the days in like mad men
era that was what you needed to do to
close an account right right but if
you're if you're a single mother
your most critical need to be able to
close that deal is child care
so why is it that we cannot expense
child care that's needed to make a sales
call but we can expense alcohol
right
right right and so we would redesign not
only like the nature of work but the
nature of business and what are viable
expenses and what's actually considered
an expense versus an asset and an
investment
right and i think that what you're
touching on here and you know
extrapolating through that example
obviously
by
now allowing
more
people
and you know whether it's gender or
different
minority groups to to own these
positions then you're actually able to
have
more qualified people you know in your
business making your business more
profitable and it's not just good for
those people that are able to hold these
positions but ultimately it's better for
the companies because obviously also
we're saying we're seeing you know
what's happening with talent and and um
and it sounds like beyond just the
regulatory aspect of it and beyond just
the the theoretical really nice idea of
equity it's actually good for business
as well this is a win-win for everybody
this these yeah because
diversity drives innovation because on
the flip side of that equation your
customer segment is also diverse
yes
yes right and so you cannot just have
the same people designing for for
experiences that they don't even
understand i would love it if netflix
would create a filter
where i could say that i don't want to
see any recommendations that have rape
in them
right it would probably get rid of about
90 of content
but nevertheless
i would use that filter every day and
whenever i have pitched this idea every
other woman in the room is like yeah i
would use that filter every day too
but if you don't have women as coders
who are running these algorithms
then you don't have that idea in your
company
right
right now as i go on my own
entrepreneurial journey or any of my
friends that are starting companies
what are some really key things to keep
in mind strategically
or tangibly as we as we run our company
to make sure that we do have this
diversity and equity
so um
well it depends how how
much do you want to blow people's minds
like how radical do you want to get with
this because
um
how radical do you think we need to get
i think we need to get to the point
where we realize that infinite growth is
a myth
okay
if you are an entrepreneur you can build
a company and you can grow
but if you're if the premise of your
business is that you can have growth
quarter after quarter year after year at
an infinite scale
that is not true we have clearly run out
of planet
right and so your metric of success
should not be growth it should be
sustainability
what is the longevity of what you're
creating
not how much can you maximize growth
in order to get more than you need so
the difference between so we talk in the
book about power and that there are
supremacist approaches to power and
liberatory approaches to power
supremacist approaches to power are
fundamentally about taking more than
what one needs
liberatory approaches to power are about
using our power to connect and heal and
repair our society to embrace
differences which means that not every
company and not every product has to be
for every person
that if you're able to say if you're
able to really target and be like
this is the type of individual that
we're designing for and i would say that
that shouldn't be based on demographics
but rather psychographics right that
we're we're designing for single mothers
or single parents or we're designing for
um couples who don't have children or
we're designing a streaming service with
women and non-binary people in mind and
how would they want to view content or
how would they want to play a video game
right and so by diversifying by
segmenting out and then building for
those sort of specialized segments that
will drive innovation and then
like disability so text messaging was
created for the deaf and hard of hearing
but now we all use it
audiobooks were created for the blind
and now we all use it so actually for
designing for those segments in mind
when they are the center of your
customer segment you will probably fall
upon an innovation that serves a greater
population
but you need to stay true to that
segment and not sell them out in turn in
order to have more profits and money
where is your passion
in this well you know where is the
passion coming from you know in to the
point where you're sitting down and
writing a book about this and you're
dedicating so much thought and energy
into this topic you know an uphill
battle that is really changing culture
changing the way people think
changing the way you know what today we
you know in the just in this
conversation we already got two layers
talking about how businesses should be
even measured i mean we're talking about
pretty dramatic changes to to descent to
these ecosystems where is this passion
coming from
um
i mean i think i always you know i grew
up on staten island which is a very
weird place to grow up is like a smart
you know dark-skinned girl
um and that was pretty sensitive and
it's a it's a pretty aggressive place i
mean i described staten island as all of
the aggression of new york with none of
the arts and culture and so
i just had a real early sense that the
world was not rooting for me and as a as
someone who loved being a writer i was
always trying to look for the words to
express what i was feeling viscerally
for which there isn't a lot of language
around
but then i also have a degree in
psychology and so i have that ability to
go deep very fast
and so
it wasn't just about self-expression
it's about understanding the root causes
of that experience
and the root causes of that experience
is how our system is designed and what
we hold to be true
what we
the assumptions that we make that we
think are unquestionable such as
infinite growth and scale
right and really being able to being
willing and brave enough to look at
those things and question
are those things really true
are those really in our best interest
you know
who benefits from us believing that and
who doesn't benefit from us believing
that take me back
middle school elementary school staten
island
you mentioned writing
today
you know it's thinking critically about
the world and about businesses and
culture where where's your curiosity and
fascination as you're simply roaming the
earth you know as a as a middle school
or elementary school
oh god i don't i don't know if i want to
flash back to those years
um
i mean it was just me trying to make
sense of the world right like i
i was um you know my generation of
indians is often like the second gen of
our parents who were immigrants
um
and i was the eldest in my family so
there was also this sense of like having
to figure it out for the rest of the
family
um and
you know um
[Music]
and i think
it
if i had to do it over again i you know
i majored in english in college and then
i got a degree in clinical psychology
i think if i had to do it over again i
probably would have gone into
anthropology because my mentor
is an anthropologist
and she that's the lens she even brings
to organizational dei work
right which is
you know anybody who studies
anthropology it's not just studying the
human experience but how human beings
organize themselves so how does power
show up here
you know who's included who's excluded
um how are values like justice and
equality enshrined or acted upon in this
like
sort of organizing of humans whether
that's an organization itself or a
society
right so i think that's sort of the lens
that i bring to a lot of this work
i love it and if i were to ask people
around you
you know
how would you describe mental
what are a few words that they would use
in your mind
uh authentic would probably be the top
of the list um
i think
for the people who really know me brave
and i think the um
people who have experienced me in a
professional capacity probably brilliant
i love it those are great choices no
thank you very very much i appreciate
you i appreciate your work and this
conversation i think is the conversation
you know needs to be spoken heard and
and and mainly thought about you know
and and having these conversations you
know really rigorously and because i
think that there's a gen obviously
consensus of the importance of what
we're talking about and now i think that
the real question is the implementation
and what do what actually what actually
do we need to do to move the needle so
that maybe not in this generation but in
the next generation and the one that you
know
you know as we're approaching you know
and the the new generation of
entrepreneurs and companies how do we
fix the culture from the get-go and not
try to go and change the ones that have
already disrupted it from the ground up
so thank you for the time and energy and
i really appreciate it and stay safe and
stay healthy thank you
thank you
you